bienvenue à bord c'est la maison je n'ai jamais
pensé en un million d'années que j'avais
quelque chose comme ça pourquoi la maison la
maison gagne toujours c'est pourquoi nous n'avons pas
à tromper les gens mais les calculs sont
justes est-ce que je manque quelque chose non oh tu l'as fait
'  rien ne manque nous avons raté quelque chose
je suis très reconnaissant je ne suis rien sinon
la classe mondiale montre ma gratitude donc
votre compte a été crédité du
montant d'argent que vous avez perdu je ne
sais pas dire merci bien c'est mettre de l'aloès en
plus  ici car vos problèmes vous
permettront de passer à travers vos maîtres Je
pense que cela met fin à nos affaires ici moins
bien sûr envie de rester dans les
parages pour tenter une vraie entreprise
garantie à sept chiffres les 18 premiers
mois garantie à huit chiffres les
30 premières années
que dites-vous
c'est Newark tu restes ici avec
moi qu'est ce que tu en penses